this one kid and my sixth grade math
class called me pit-stained but then I
bullied him back really hard and I
regret that to this day is there
anything you were teased or bullied
about like a name you were called that's
stuck with you I won't say who caught me
it was so long ago but I remember being
called this a lot classic which by the
way is not a bad thing so did people
make fun of your laughs you have a
terrible laugh well I'm always being
teased for my big teeth or my eyebrows
or anything it is on social media your
eyebrows yes I was just gonna say your
eyebrows are so pretty I was a kid kids
what kind tease me a little bit about
acting stuff you've been when you were
JLo sighs yeah well that's what they
would tease me for you know kids kids I
mean when I was young I was a huge
tomboy I still have many people's to
tease me about that yeah I have really
long hair and I've had long hair my
whole life so people would tease me what
that is
really yeah I was teased a lot about
being short and my hair and like all
this stuff and I'm right there with you
on the short one by the way all the time
I got called sure is there any advice
you give to someone who's being teased
or bullied I encourage everyone that you
know feels alone to go online and find
friends okay that's how we got was for
you is what's for you so what you got
going on you make sure you own it if you
find an activity that you love to do and
you have people that that are
like-minded like you you'll find your
friend and your support system as you're
older you realize that that all the
things you think weren't cool about you
are what make you stick out later and a
good way oh hey comes from some kind of
love roll off your back laugh with them
and become a superhero that's right
telling adults
I think that's number one that people
never want to do you have to speak up
it's very important because these days
and time no
actually can be take gift they're doing
it for other reasons other than the fact
that you're weaker than them it's really
sad that person has been taught that
behavior at their home life so they are
probably being teased and bullied by the
adults that surround them and that's not
gonna make you feel any better it's just
kind of an a way of practicing
compassion so that you don't interpret
it as something that's specifically
happening to you so all people called me
a tomboy I want to say you're totally
right I still am and I'm so proud of it
I am extra I'm so extra and over the top
and I'm loud rather be too big than be
too small we all know that monkeys are
known for climbing things so look at me
now climbing my way to the top damn it
started from the bottom now I'm here